after the cacophony that was March with
its enthusiastic reminders of how
explosive and intense games can be the
quietude of April was a welcome reprieve
the slow trickle of releases forced us
to savor each offering we spent
countless hours willing our trials
fusion rider to stay upright striving
for record times as we incessantly
belted out the lyrics to the electric
opening theme and we devoured the wolf
among us a crooked mile relishing each
telling growl as this fantastical story
infected our very being April was that
kind of month a time to dissect each
game and to lose ourselves in their
enticing worlds but it was child of
light that had the most profound effect
on us the dreamlike artistic design
danced before us and coupled with the
melodic piano score captivated our
senses in uncommon ways because it
wasn't the light-hearted fair that child
of lights delicate palate hinted at but
rather one of deep sorrow born of the
utter hopelessness of a land whose
societal aspirations have been smothered
and so we opened our hearts to this
strange place and in turn felt as one
with its citizens as we took personal
interests in their determined plates
there's a remarkable maturity present in
child light you can see it from its firm
confidence how it so expertly conjures
such difficult emotions instead of
shying away from them there's a united
focus that's incredibly rare the
dialogue is so defeated the landscape is
so barren that you feel the weight of
all the problems of this planned and
want nothing more than to bring a little
happiness to those who are hurting so
and that's why the shift when you enter
battle when you finally set aside the
overbearing difficulties consuming you
and focus on the immediate threat is
such a relief all of your pent-up
emotions can be unleashed in a swallow
of anger as you blot out the enemies
before you child of light is so
soft-spoken that you have to lean in
close to hear what it's saying but it
lifted our spirits despite its sorrel
mood and reminded us what it's like to
be human that's a singular achievement
in the realm of video games where so
many games are willing to strip away any
semblance of who we truly are and we're
thankful that such a powerful mirror
to our own hearts exists